la función de estas primarias en las que
es obligatorio votar excepto para los
menores de 18 años aquellos que tienen
entre 16 y 17 años pueden votar pero no
es obligatorio tampoco es obligatorio
para los mayores de 70 decía el objetivo
de estas elecciones es que las fuerzas
puedan decidir cuál de sus listas si
presentan más de una será la que compita
el 14 de noviembre en las elecciones
legislativas propiamente dichas algunas
y algunos partidos no presentan más de
una lista así que también sirve como una
forma de medir fuerzas entre los
diferentes partidos de cara al 14 de
noviembre y también para que la
población los ciudadanos entiendan cuál
es el mapa que se empieza a dibujar de
cara a esas elecciones y tal vez
reflexionen de forma diferente respecto
a cómo quieren votar como este año las
elecciones son en el contexto de
pandemia algunas medidas para tratar de
prevenir y evitar los contagios por un
lado se han sumado centros de votación
para distribuir más a los votantes
también se va a pedir que la gente esté
respetando una distancia de dos metros
entre sí mientras espera para votar que
lleve su propio bolígrafo
será para las anotaciones que tengan que
hacer y se va a evitar el contacto entre
entre votantes y autoridades de mesa lo
más posible también habrá un horario
especial durante la mañana para aquellas
personas que son de riesgo las mesas se
abren para la votación a las 8 de la
mañana de argentina se cierran a las 18
horas también de argentina y a las 23 se
espera que estén los primeros resultados